health workers and ngos are stepping up
their operations and Quake hit regions
of Southern turkey with growing concerns
about the spread of infectious diseases
Hashem reports from
a Race Against Time to clear the rubble
and Mirage is among the Region's hardest
hit by earthquakes in southern turkey
drinking water isn't safe the air is
thick with dust and health experts say
it's contaminated with toxins and
pollutants from the rubble
our biggest challenge in improving
hygiene and sanitary conditions
especially now that you have a growing
number of displaced living in tents and
camps our goal is to provide better
living conditions for them
in this makeshift Camp those without
homes receive bottled water masks hand
sanitizers and daily supplies of food
clearly traumatized they face an
uncertain future
teams clear the rubble huge challenges
are piling up the hundreds of thousands
of people affected by the earthquakes
will stay in shelters or relocated to
safer houses until theirs are rebuilt
but in the meantime they will continue
to be exposed to the threats of
aftershocks diseases and toxins in the
air
David whitwick leads a team of doctors
from the UK and he's worried it's
inevitable that you're going to see a
rise in disease and it's also inevitable
there will be some kind of infectious
disease the only issue is how quickly we
can get on top of it all together and
control it
for now people in karaman marash are
desperate to retrieve their belongings
this is all volunteers could recover
from this building a photo album for the
family that once lived here but they
hope it will help survivors and
relatives of those who have died to pick
up the pieces and move on marash
let's get the latest on efforts in
Turkey a now I can speak to Rob McBride
who is live in the city of Adana we know
the government has been under huge
profit pressure to provide shelter for
people how is that going are people
getting the help they need
yeah that is the effort now to build
these uh temporary container cities as
they're called in the disaster affected
area but there is also a growing
awareness here about the pop the problem
of population displacement you've had
this disaster affecting literally
millions of people it's estimated
several million people have actually
left this corner of turkey eight for
other parts of the country now many of
those people will have gone to the much
bigger cities like Istanbul and Ankara
but a sizable proportion of people will
have gone not that far away from their
home provinces to places like here Adena
on the edge of the earthquake zone and
also other cities further west down the
coast for example the big Port City of
Madison now that is about the first big
city you come to which is considered
safe if you like it's just outside of
the earthquake zone so it's estimated
and some of the these estimates do vary
but it's reckoned that maybe several
hundred thousand people have suddenly
arrived within the past couple of weeks
which is a big influence blocks of
people for a provincial City so it's
putting a real strain on resources in
places like uh like Marcin we know that
many of those people who are being
accommodated in temporary accommodation
in gymnasiums in government dormitories
and so on they will return to their home
provinces once temporary the places are
built for them there but increasingly it
seems the people who've lost livelihoods
who've lost their homes may never go
back and you are seeing things like
rental prices in Mars in double in some
cases they are expecting to see a big
demand for Hospital resources for school
places and so on as the population
suddenly swells so places like Mars in
other cities especially close to the
earthquake affected area are all facing
these problems and it's a big problem
for turkey itself looking at the
recovery not just during the emergency
stage but further on into the medium and
long term okay Rob McBride there for us
in Adana in Turkey